THE STATE OF GOOGLE:
I’m sure you’re all familiar with Google’s
Moonshot factory.
It’s the home of Google’s most ambitious
projects form Google Glass and Waymo to Loon
and Verily.
Even before the moonshot factory was formally
founded in 2010, Google was at the forefront
of technological development and advancement.
But, it appears that this has been changing
over the past couple of years.
Like any corporation, Google has become more
focused on profits and pleasing shareholders
than making massive bets.
We no longer see those over the top presentations
from Sergey Brin and Larry Page.
Nor do we hear about Google making much tangible
progress with self driving.
This trend has simply been exacerbated by
the recession.
In September, Google cancelled up to half
of their R&D projects across the company.
And more recently, it was reported that Google
is diverting much of its moonshot factory
efforts into revenue generating projects.
This trend doesn’t just apply to Google’s
Moonshot factory either.
It’s actually a larger trend that can be
observed across the company.
Many Google veterans have raised concerns
that Google’s culture has become unrecognizable.
And the recent layoffs are just one example
of that.
The old Google would have done anything to
prevent layoffs similar to Southwest.
If you didn’t know, Southwest has never
done layoffs despite facing way more tumultuous
times than Google from the 1973 oil crisis
and 2001 to 2008 and the pandemic.
Meanwhile, Google is posting near record profits
and chose to layoff 12,000 people mostly due
to shareholder concerns.
But likely the best example of Google turning
the corner is the fact that they dropped their
famous slogan “Don’t Be Evil”.
In 2015, Google added a new motto to their
code of conduct “Do the right thing” before
dropping the original slogan in 2018.
This massive shift didn’t just happen over
night though.
So, here’s the slow devolution of Google
from being the ambitious startup that was
at the forefront of tech to being the background
company that just wants to stay in their lane.
COMPLACENT EMPLOYEES:
When you think about a career at Google, one
of the first things that come to mind are
the high compensation, prestige, and influence.
For decades, Google has prided themselves
with paying the absolute highest salaries
and from a statistical standpoint, this is
still very much true.
In 2021, Alphabet once again topped the median
employee salary list coming in with a median
compensation of $295,000.
Combine this with the insane perks that Google
offers like their free food and remote working
opportunities, and you would think that Google
employees are living the high life and objectively
speaking they are.
But, happiness is very much a relative thing,
and for people working at Google, all of these
perks are very much the norm.
Not to mention, Google isn’t the only company
where they can enjoy these benefits.
Until recently, the number of options that
these people had was unprecedented leading
them to feel unsatisfied and yes undercompensated.
I know that’s probably hard to believe,
so I’ve got survey results to back this
up.
Back in early 2022, Business Insider found
that only a mere 46% of surveyed Google employees
were happy with their compensation.
In other words, over half of Google’s workforce
thinks that their compensation isn’t competitive.
And this feeling is simply getting stronger
every year.
Back in 2020, 64% of Google’s employees
felt that their compensation was competitive.
This number dropped to 56% in 2021 before
dropping to 46%.
Much of these can be explained by even stronger
offers coming from startups like Coinbase
and Stripe.
But, it’s not just the compensation that
Googlers are upset with either.
Many also feel that the company is becoming
more bureaucratic and less transparent.
Within the cloud division, for example, only
54% of employees feel that the promotional
process is fair.
You can decipher this in two ways.
Either, you can think that these guys are
simply spoiled brats who don’t realize how
good they have it.
Or, you can think that these truly guys truly
do have a lot more potential like become a
founder or an executive.
Either way though, the end feeling is the
same: unhappy and unmotivated employees.
And this feeling only leads to two things:
high attrition and/or a stagnant workforce.
The high attrition is no secret.
At Alphabet, the median tenure is only a mere
1.3 years.
This statistic is skewed by new hires, but
that doesn’t really make the statistic all
that much better.
Speaking of new hires, Google has been aggressively
recruiting and growing their workforce over
the past 10 years.
Between 2009 and 2021, Google’s workforce
grew from 20,000 employees to 156,000 employees.
And realistically speaking, it’s significantly
harder to maintain the same culture and caliber
across 156,000 people than it is to maintain
it across 20,000 people.
It’s more than likely that a substantial
portion of these new hires were simply looking
for the compensation and resume boost.
And when you have too many of these people,
it’s just a matter of time until your company
becomes soulless.
COMPLACENT EXECUTIVES:
It’s common for founders to have a bunch
of beef with shareholders.
Mark Zuckerburg, for example, is actively
fighting the entire world when it comes to
pursuing the Metaverse.
This was very much the same case with Google’s
founders: Larry Page & Sergey Brin.
And this strife between investors and executives
is very much what gave Google it’s unique
culture.
In 2001, for example, Larry Page went ahead
and fired all of Google’s project managers.
The reasoning?
Well, Page felt that engineers didn’t need
anyone to give them directions and that they
shouldn’t be forced to follow arbitrary
deadlines.
HR did end up reversing this decision, but
this gives us a glimpse of just how Page felt
about managers and why Google ended up being
such an engineering driven company.
Similarly, Sergey felt that no one should
be 200 feet away from food.
And this is why Google has so much food everywhere
despite it being rather uneconmical.
Many of Google’s most iconic moves were
such unorthodox rebellious actions.
Both Page and Brin had a history of completing
acquisitions without consulting with anyone
else in the company including even the official
CEO.
This was the case with even Android and Google
Earth.
We should also note that this approach led
to a bunch of failures like Google Glass,
but the takeaway isn’t that the founders
were rebellious.
The takeaway is that the founders didn’t
care about bureaucracy or angry shareholders,
and that their main goal was simply doing
the best thing for the company.
This is actually the main reason that both
founders actually left Google.
They felt that they could no longer do what
was right for the company and that there was
simply too much red tape to keep fighting.
Conversely, Google’s new leadership isn’t
put off by the red tape.
In fact, you could even argue that they like
the red tape as it gives them purpose, definition,
and meaning.
Their jobs as executives is to make shareholders
happy and to constantly grow earnings quarter
after quarter.
And from this perspective, Sundar Pichai has
hit it out of the park.
Since he became CEO in 2015, Google stock
has grown as much as 5X.
And even with the recession, Google is up
4X.
A similar story can be seen with Google’s
fundamentals as well.
Since 2015, Google’s revenue has grown from
$70 billion to $280 billion and their net
income has grown from $15 billion to over
$70 billion.
So, clearly, Sundar has given shareholders
exactly what they wanted, but this very much
came with a cost.
To accomplish such growth, Google couldn’t
focus on random out there projects that were
very much a gamble.
Instead, Google had to double down on their
revenue generating sectors such as ads and
the cloud and focus on making these endeavors
as profitable as possible.
And that’s exactly what they did.
They cut out all the fluff.
But, while this seemed like fluff for shareholders,
this was what made Google Google.
And without it, Google became just another
soulless tech corporation.
PUBLIC SENTIMENT:
While much of the new Google has to do with
a shift in leadership and employee culture,
not all of it can be attributed to Google
themselves.
Much of the old Google was formed by public
sentiment and much of the new Google is also
formed by public sentiment.
In fact, you could argue that Google’s public
sentiment was what made them so successful
in the first place.
Take Gmail for example.
Much of Gmail’s appeal came from the fact
that it was exclusive, had generous storage,
and was anti Yahoo and Microsoft.
The same thing could be said about Chrome.
Much of Chrome’s appeal came from the fact
that it was fast, reliable, and anti Internet
Explorer and Microsoft.
Google had built this image as the white knight
savior tech company that wasn’t evil.
But, the sentiment around Google has shifted
substantially over the past 15 years.
Google is no longer the startup taking on
the big players.
Google is the big player.
Not to mention, Google has also built up a
rather negative reputation when it comes to
data collection and privacy.
We’ve all seen those memes that Alexa, Google,
and Siri are always listening.
This sentiment hurts the company in two ways.
For one, the public is less likely to support
new products that come from the company.
A great example of this is with Google Fi,
their cell phone plan.
Objectively speaking, Google Fi offers extremely
generous plans that come in way cheaper than
the competition.
This is the same formula that Google used
with Gmail and Google Fiber to great success.
But, most people don’t even know about Google
Fi because the cellular space already had
an anti carrier player: T-Mobile.
If anything, Google was viewed more like AT&T
or Verizon than they were as T-Mobile.
And this makes sense because Google was essentially
trying to control you smartphone, your OS,
the things that you do on your phone, and
your connection.
And if the public isn’t willing to support
a cell phone plan, it’s much less likely
that they’ll support something that’s
truly out there.
I mean just take a look at Facebook.
Sure, the Metaverse is underwhelming, but
I’d bet that much of its criticism comes
from people’s already negative opinion of
Facebook.
The Metaverse wouldn’t be nearly as ridiculed
if it wasn’t associated with Facebook and
Mark Zuckerberg.
For obvious reasons, Google doesn’t want
to go down the same path, so they’ve decided
to simply play it on the safe side.
Aside from the public not be receptive to
new products, a negative stigma also makes
it much more difficult to attract the best
talent.
Google is not the top company that engineering
students want to work for.
The top companies that engineering students
want to work for are SpaceX and Tesla, and
those companies don’t even pay crazy salaries
or offer ridiculous perks.
As more and more talented engineers flock
to such companies and startups, it’s no
wonder why Google is no longer pushing the
boundaries.
THE FUTURE OF GOOGLE:
In the end, Google was iconic for setting
outrageous goals and going all in regardless
of how ridiculous it makes them look or the
odds of success.
But eversince Larry and Sergey left, Google
has become much more tame mostly due to complacent
employees, a priority to please shareholders,
and a rapidly deteriorating public image.
Given that Google’s revenue and net income
was growing faster than they can count for
the past several years, Google didn’t have
any problems keeping some out there projects
alive.
But, now that Google can feel the pressure
on their bottom line, Google is shifting to
take decisive action.
This isn’t to say that Google will be screwed
or that this move will backfire.
In fact, I’m sure that this move will work
out great financially.
But, at the same time, this is just another
example of Google taking another step closer
to becoming a Cisco or an Intel, and that’s
truly quite a shame.
Are you a fan of the New Google?
Comment that down below.
Also, drop a like if you miss the old Google.
And of course, consider checking out our discord
community to suggest future video ideas and
consider subscribing to see more questions
logically answered.